okay so linda i watched a strange
harvest and i saw there was this lady
who via hypnotherapy was able to see a
cow being abducted and i'm wondering if
there are any other cases of people
seeing a cattle being mutilated or being
taken but not in some post-induced
altered state
probably one of the most interesting
aspects at the beginning of the research
when i started calling sheriffs and
deputies back in for the first time
september of 1979
i was provoked by headlines that were in
colorado newspapers and television using
the word
animal mutilations returned
and i had been doing medical programming
for the abc station in boston
have moved to denver and was hired to be
director of special projects but i was
personally not aware of the animal
mutilation phenomena having been working
at knbc in los angeles and wcvb in
boston so that when i saw these
headlines
the first thing that i did was contact
sheriffs in some of the counties that
were listed
and one of them was sheriff tech's
graves up in logan county in colorado
and
um drove up for a probably it was about
a three or four hour meeting
in which he brought out
polaroids and
documents
and he had been investigating animal
mutilation since uh i think it was 1970
or 71 and i'm now a decade later in his
office
asking him as director of special
projects
it was sheriff tex graves who told me
linda i'll save you some time
the perpetrators are creatures from
outer space
and then he began to tell me why which
included his own interviews with
ranchers that he had gone out to
investigate
bloodless trackless mutilations who said
at night
i saw a beam
i saw a beam coming out of something
circular in the night sky
it was coming down into the pasture
the rancher would say i was terrified
ran back to the ranch house and then
when the sun came up
went out
and there was
one of his cattle
bloodlessly
mutilated meaning an ear is taken
on the sky facing the animals are
usually on one side
and it's the sky facing that always is
where the ear is taken
the eye is taken sometimes a circle of
flesh around the eye
the jaw like a key hole
they called it the keyhole cut where
it's like this
and everything is removed
and fresh shining bone
and was one of the points that
sheriff tex graves said not only were
the ranchers reporting that they were
seeing beams of light coming into their
pasture where they would find a
mutilated animal
but you can ask a veterinarian how would
you get
this
tissue
off of a jaw bone when of the only way
to get a jawbone
clean and polished is to boil
and that is not happening between in the
hours between the day and when they're
found in the morning and when this one
particular rancher the sheriff tex
graves was saying
saw the beam of light
eventually i would hear in
discussions with other sheriffs and
deputies
where they would be talking with a
rancher who would say
they saw an animal rise in the beam of
light
but it was not a cell phone age we're
talking about the early 70s so you have
human testimony of what they have seen
but you do not have
video recordings or photographs
and
i think it was the sheriff tex graves
comment
linda i'll save you some time
the perpetrators are creatures from
outer space
and that was to me the most shocking
statement to me in the very first
interview with a sheriff that i
conducted
did the person see an eight a cattle a
cow going up or he just saw the beam at
that point
that particular rancher saw the beam
others would then
later on tell me about how they saw an
animal rise
or be lowered and in
my work uh glimpses of other realities
uh
high strangeness
and in facts and eyewitnesses it's a
two-volume book there is a story
out of
oregon
and that was an eyewitness that i was
able to interview
he was working as a ranch hand was
staying out in a trailer house where
they had uh some cattle that might uh be
giving birth and so he would stay out to
help if anything happened with the
cattle
and he
was uh he started hearing a sound and
couldn't understand what he was hearing
on a clear night
it sounded like branches breaking and he
left the trailer house and to his
complete and total astonishment
he was seeing
uh a light there was a beam but cattle
were dropping
from whatever this light was in the sky
they were dropping down through the
trees breaking branches
and it was like 11 animals
that he himself
watched drop from the sky
and that was uh in southeastern oregon
and it's one of the uh
cases that i have documented by talking
with him and others who were in oregon
at the time
and the animal mutilations have had
cyclings in certain areas whether it's
the united states canada mexico central
america cycling with respect to time
what do you mean
global it is a global phenomenon that
cycles
if uh
in this instance like i can think of
times
well there was a rancher named blazing
game
and he had a big ranch that was north of
colorado springs in colorado
and i interviewed him when i was working
on my documentary a strange harvest
and
then about three years later
he called me at the station and he said
i want you to know
that hill pasture
that we talked about where i had the
mutilations he said this year i decided
i was not going to put any cattle on
that hill pasture and linda this is the
first year
in four years i have not had a
mutilation
and that has always been to me another
one of those data points that has been
puzzling
that you get the sense in the animal
mutilations as if there was a grid on
the planet
and that certain latitude longitudes
would continue to repeat over time
where a rancher would say i had the
mutilations on in this pasture and no
other pastures
on that hill pasture
and that is also a puzzle why do you
think that is
well if we are dealing with
extraterrestrial biological entities as
sheriff tex graves said
their approach to our planet
could be
let's say
let's say because one of the hypotheses
is
that the reason for the animal
mutilations relates to the fact that the
gray beings that have been
probably reported more than any other in
abductions
and have been seen
uh
two cowboys
in colorado
uh they were reported and called the
sheriff
that they saw
two small gray beings literally float in
the air up over a corral fence and down
into a corral scared them and they ran
away and then they come back and there
is a mutilated cow in the corral so they
had a direct link with the gray beings
um
that
one of the hypotheses
is that
um all these different types that are
reported around the world
grey types reptilian types tall blondes
tall whites all of these different types
of beings
that there may be
an evolutionary
relationship between
say grays that may have been working on
our planet for centuries maybe thousands
and thousands of years
we
are a species that has only existed
on earth for 45 000 years in the
crossfade with neanderthalensis
so we would not have any first-hand
information about what was happening on
our earth in terms of
extraterrestrials and animal mutilations
uh prior to let's say the 20th century
and one of the hypotheses is that the
harvest may be because there are certain
chemicals
that beings that have been on this
planet for
millennia
may have developed that they had a need
for something
to be healthy
and that can only get it from earth life
and that that is why there is this
periodic
cyclic global harvest of blood and
tissue from animals both
uh domestic
and wild the
forest service had photographs of deer
elk other places kangaroos
reindeer are there ever small animals
like rats or cats
cats cut in half
all over the planet
usually leaving
the front half more than the back half
no blood inside no organs inside that's
part of the animal mutilations
a marmot
a marmot was reported in aspen colorado
to me
uh it was a forest service guy and he
found the marmot laid out on a rock
and it had the same ear
eye
jaw
so here's this little animal that had
the same excisions as the larger they're
all mammals
um no because
i think
well what category would you put a
kangaroo in mammal
okay
okay so
they're not reptiles
there have been uh snakes
in england
that have been found where a fox was
mutilated or a
rabbit was mutilated and then they would
find nearby a reptile snake that was cut
with organs removed very specifically
from inside the snake
with no blood and no fluid and
completely dry
you mentioned that there was a report of
two grays and then they came and floated
and i imagine that they're floating
without a beam so the beam was to bring
up a cow to make a cow float so they can
float on their own without
light let's say is there a difference
between a ground mutilation and one that
takes place in the craft itself
i don't know beyond the fact that in
myerfiles.com
i have about 3 000 in-depth reports in
science and environment and real x-files
and there is a fascinating report
where there were two men they had gone
out to hunt
and
they uh were in sleeping bags and they
both become aware
that
that there is some kind of a beam
that is taking one of the hunters up out
of a sleeping bag the other watches and
then they both
find themselves inside of a craft
and that was a case where
a cow
was all hooked up to tubes to a strange
technology
and their testimony was that
telepathically that they were receiving
information from a clearly looking
standing up uh alligator lizard type
this is what we do
we we take your this animal and it's
important that it remain alive while we
are removing the fluids
it's the only case that i know of where
there was a
effort to try to communicate to humans
who were watching
a process of lifting this was a cow
going up in a beam of light uh that the
hunters saw
and then showing what had happened now
why that would be
that is part of the mystery
why is it that the for the most part
animal mutilations have taken place
around the planet usually in what would
be the dark hours of night that would be
the general and then the animals found
in the morning
but in these cases which are not many
where there have been humans who see the
beam
in this case
the only case i know where two men are
then up inside of the craft and being
shown this is what we do
why did that happen and why hasn't it
happened on lots of other cases
it is part of the mystery
of non-human intelligences who have been
interacting with this planet
from government uh testimony to me from
people who have worked in nsacidia
saying
as one man told me in december of 1999
uh he was retiring from the defense
intelligence agency
and we had a seven hour meeting that
took a month to put together uh and he
said
uh that
the
uh
the whole issue of how long
all of this had been going on he said
our government
has proof
that three extraterrestrial
civilizations
have been competing with each other and
in conflict on our planet for at least
270 million years
and when i said what is the proof
he said linda if i told you
it would be a danger to you and to me
both
but 270 million years is going back
before the time of the dinosaurs
did they give any indication that the
cows were being lowered slower when you
said that they heard rustling when the
cows were being lowered into some ground
are they being are they being dropped
are they being lowered slowly
i've heard both
the one in uh oregon
that was the first hand
the cowboy watching because he heard the
breaking limbs and sees the animals
dropping he could see a beam but they
were being dropped
from the beam through the trees
other cases
people see they like the linda porter
case that you mentioned
she and her daughter
see a calf rising up in a beam of light
and then they find themselves in the
craft with gray beings that are taking
thin slices from testicles and other
organs
that they associate with the calf that
they saw go up in the beam of light
so you have variations on
watching something
be lowered
i've had cases they've seen it lowered
all the way but the rancher becomes
terrified and runs back to a ranch house
and does not come back to that pasture
till the sun is up and then they find a
mutilated animal other people see them
dropped
and
and why
for the most part the vast majority
don't see either
they find the animals
what's meant precisely when you say that
there is no blood i've heard this many
times so does that mean that if i was to
take my finger and touch the inside that
it would come out without any red or is
it just that there isn't a drastic
amount of blood it's radically reduced
uh you have uh
one or two of my books and you look at
the photographs and you see
an excision
eye
ear the jaw the genitals the rectum over
and over thousands and thousands of
photos around the world the same
there's not even fluid there's no blood
there's no blood oozing there's no blood
on the ground
everything is dry
what about urine or excrement
i don't
recall i don't think a single
animal mutilation case
because usually in 90 of the cases the
rectal tissue is removed
and that means it's a hole
and there's no blood and there's no
fluid and as a lot of sheriffs have said
to me it felt like sand paper to touch
the tissue
it was so dry